Furious comes to life tomorrow at Las
Vegas Motor Speedway with fuel Fest and
the man behind it all is Cody Walker
he's with us right now thanks for
joining us today thank you for having me
this is awesome well fuel Fest what's
going on at the track tomorrow what do
you have going on oh man you know I call
it an automotive celebration bringing
together enthusiasts of all types
classic cars muscle cars JDM tuner cars
exotic cars the whole shebang and it's
just like it's not just a car show it's
not just a static car show there's
action all day long we've got drifting
got a tip top 16 competition we've got
free stuff we're giving out and prizes
all day long and music and it's just
it's awesome man it is a huge party what
do we have here a nice little Ferrari
here we have Ferraris out there we're
doing drifting competitions tomorrow we
are yeah
um I I really like every single show
we've ever this is our first time in
Vegas doing a fuel Fest so at Vegas
Motor Speedway is a great venue and we
always have every Everything represented
like Exotics Ferraris you know
Koenigseggs we've had at all at all the
shows let's walk it down and see some of
the cars we have here because you had
this in Tokyo recently and do you have
over a thousand cars out there oh yeah
it was north of a thousand cars we had
33 000 people at the event yeah yeah it
was really cool and you have
entertainment out there now you're the
brother of the late Paul Walker and and
this is this is a very important event
for you because you're continuing his
legacy and he also have a charity tie-in
tell us more about the the importance of
continuing your brother's Legacy yeah so
his Charities called Reach Out worldwide
they help people and families after
severe weather and natural disasters so
that's uh you know medical needs or
helping to rebuild homes after uh floods
hurricane Ian most recent thing we've
been very active over in Florida helping
homeowners out there that homes were
were destroyed and with every fuel Fest
show we contribute a portion of the
proceeds to reach out worldwide and
we've exceeded over 200 Grand at this
point so it's really cool it's extra
special right it doesn't if there's not
a if there's not a purpose behind it
like what's what's the purpose right and
what do we have here what kind of car we
have here uh this is a Nissan uh this is
an r33 this is a EC right so this is
rb25 so Caden though can tell you all
about this is his baby
get over here you imported this right
you went through all the paperwork yeah
so we actually I actually imported this
uh last year in October it got here in
December so uh right hand drive we're
standing on the passenger side right now
but I've had a lot of fun with it and
you do drifting you compete uh I do not
I wish I did uh you know one day that
would be super cool this one's kind of
more of just a street car for now but
over in Japan they like like to use
these every now and then I love it about
30 seconds go into the last car why
don't you come down here in this last
car here how do people get tickets by
the way Cody uh fuelfest.com and and
what kind of car do you have here I got
a super here Target top also rarely
imported from Japan also right hand
drive so it's
beautiful yeah what's it like for you to
meet Cody Walker and be a part of this
event tomorrow insane yeah yeah
definitely a dream come true I grew up
watching the movies I'm a big part of
like helping out foundations and
everything like that so it's it's
amazing to be able to be a part of and
help out okay real quick I said it back
inside real quick you could have any car
out there any car in the world what
would it be oh come on
the reason why I can't answer this
question is it's probably going to
change that's true it changes you know
and it's like once it's here it's in
stone that's right that's right listen
we'll send it back to you in the studio
Rocky fuel Fest at the Las Vegas Motors